vous êtes ici au coeur du village de mes
rona il y avait cinq fermées tôt il y en
a quatre ici est un petit peu en
contrebas sur la route de plaisir il
était tout habité par des fermiers
aujourd'hui la plupart des fermes sont
des résidences secondaires et la commune
ne compte plus que huit habitants peu de
chance de rencontrer sous la pluie alors
c'est le maire de mai rona qui nous sert
de guide
vous avez ici donc le monument aux morts
de la guerre de 14 qui est une des rares
propriété de la commune avec le château
d'eau en fait un aïeul avait acheté mais
rona était après avait obtenu le titre
de seigneur de norohna c'était avant la
révolution est donc depuis toute la
famille s'appelle cameron au moyen-âge
un château-fort dominer le village il a
ensuite été transformé en manoir qui
abrite aujourd'hui plusieurs résidences
et la petite mairie c'est ici que se
réunissent les sept conseillers
municipaux et que se règlent les
affaires de la commune et monsieur le
maire a de quoi faire des envieux gras
complètement de s'entend très bien il
n'y a absolument pas de problème de voix
la personne qui voudrait faire des
choses qu'on peut pas fait et c'est donc
mon nom n'y a pas seulement aucun
problème toutes les décisions se font
tout à fait à l'unanimité on en discute
entre nous et puis voilà qu'il faut
prendre une décision on la prend sans
surprise bernard de mai rona se présente
une nouvelle fois aux municipales il
doit convaincre 21 inscrits sur la liste
électorale du village de voter pour son
équipe